بدايه من موسكو حيث تعقد اليوم قمه روسيه
صينيه تبحث علاقات البلدين وقضايا سياسه
الدوليه وبينها الحرب في اوكرانيا قبل
ساعات من زيارته الى موسكو قال الرئيس
الصيني
الى العلاقات بين موسكو وبيجين مبنيه على
مبادئ عدم الانحياز وعدم المواجهه وليست
موجهه ضد طرف ثالث واضاف في مقاله لصحف
روسيه ان الوثيقه الصينيه بشان الازمه
الاوكرانيه تشكل عاملا في تحييد تداعياتها
والدفعها نحو التسويه وشدد على ان روسيا
والصين تعملان على تعزيز الثقه المتبادله
وتخلقان نموذجا جديدا للعلاقات بين القوى
العظمى واضاف ان الصين تتخذ موقفا موضوعيا
ومحايدا بشان الازمه الاوكرانيه وتشجع على
اجراء مفاوضات للسلام
هذا وكان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن رحب
باستعداد الصين لعب ما سماه دورا بناء في
حل الازمه في اوكرانيا وقال انه يثمن ما
سماه الموقف الوازن للصين اذا النزاع في
اوكرانيا وفي مقال له في صحيفه الشعب
الصينيه قال بوتين ان روسيا والصين تدعمان
اقامه نظام عالميعادل قائم على القانون
الدولي واعتبر بوتين ان صداقه المتينه بين
البلدين تزداد عمقا وان علاقاتهما مستمره
في النمو ومتفوقه على التحالفات العسكريه
والسياسيه للحرب البارده
وفي الولايات المتحده قال منسق للاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي جون
كربي انه من الواضح ان الصين تدعم روسيا
ضمنيا قائلا انها لم تدن الحرب ولم تطبق
العقوبات على موسكو واضاف كربي في لقاء
على محطه ام اس ام بي سي الامريكيه انا
خطه وقف اطلاق النار التي اقترحتها بيجين
في اوكرانيا غير مقبوله لانها تمنح
الشرعيه لبوتين على الاراضي التي احتلتها
روسيا
ولم تطبق العقوبات عليها وتبنت دعايه
الروسيه بان مبرر الحرب هو ضغط الغرب
والتهديد الوجودي لروسيا وهذا محظوظ هراء
مقترح الصيني للسلامه في اوكرانيا والحديث
عن الحاجه الى وقف اطلاق النار وهذا غير
مقبول لانه يضفي الشرعيه على غزو روسيا
ويثبت وجودها على الارض التي احتلتها
ويمنح بوتين الوقت لاعاده ترتيب صفوفه
وتاهيل قواته انها مبادره منحزه بالكامل
الى روسيا
ومن موسكو ينضم الينا مراسلنا امين درغامي
اهلا بك امين اذا واضح عدم ترحيب امريكي
قد يكون متوقعا في المقابل
متانه وزياده عمق في العلاقات بين روسيا
والصين حدثنا عن اخر المواقف من حيث تقف
وهذا الاستقبال للضيف الصيني
نعم ليلى بلا شك ان هذه الزياره ستعطي
زخما لعلاقات تصفها كل من موسكو وبكين
بانها
الاكثر تطورا في التاريخ بين البلدين هناك
يعني رغبه
وتصميم لنقل من روسيا والصين لتطوير هذه
العلاقات
لزياده التعاون زياده حجم التبادل التجاري
بين البلدين مع طبعا
التركيز على الملفات الاستراتيجيه وايضا
بعض القضايا الدوليه على راسها مساله طبعا
العقوبات التي ترى كل من روسيا والصين على
انها تفرض بشكل غير قانوني وغير شرعي على
الدول وهناك ايضا تنسيق في كثير من
الملفات والقضايا بدات لنقل ملامح هذا
التنسيق من خلال المقالتين اللتين
ان نشرت بالتزامن مع بدايه هذه الزياره
لكل من الرئيس الروسي والرئيس الصيني بشكل
متزامن في كل من صحيفه الشعب الصينيه
وصحيفه رصيسكا
الروسيه تم الزعيمان طبعا اكد على عمق هذه
العلاقات على الرغبه المشتركه لتطويرها
وزياده حجم التبادل التجاري مع تركيز على
ملفات استراتيجيه دوليه من ابرزها طبعا
يعني
محاوله او الرغبه في تفادي احاديه القطب
عدم تجزئه الامن
وطبعا غيرها من القضايا هناك الملف
الاوكراني سيكون حاضرا بدون شك لكنه لن
يكون في صداره هذه المباحثات نتحدث عن
رغبه مشتركه للرفع ميزان التجاري الى 200
مليار دولار السنه المقبله من 185 مليار
روسيا هذه السنه احتلت المرت الاولى كاول
مصدر للغاز الطبيعي الى الصين
وطبعا
محاولات طبعا لتنويع
يعني المواد
التي تدخل طبعا في الميزان التجاري ميزان
التبادل التجاري بين البلدين وكل هذه
الملفات طبعا ستكون حاضره في هذه القمه
التي ستستمر ليومين الليله الرئيس الصيني
من المنتظر ان يصل الى موسكو بعد نحو ثلاث
ساعات سيكون هناك استقبال في الكرملين
وايضا ستكون هناك او سيكون لقاء بروتوكولي
بين الزعيمين في انتظار طبعا المباحثات
الموسعه التي سيشهدها قصر الكريملين غدا
بين الزعيمين اشكرك وطبعا سنتابع معك ثور
وصول الضيف الصيني
والتداعيات لهذه الزياره شكرا جزيلا امين
درغامي من موسكو